[موسيقى]
بالاسلحه التقليديه والنوويه الولايات
المتحده مستعده للدفاع عن كوريا الجنوبيه
من انشطه كوريا الشماليه المتساعده هذا ما
اعلن عنه وزير الدفاع الامريكي الذي يزور
سول للمره الثالثه بصفته وزيرا للدفاع
كما تلتزم الولايات المتحده من راسخا
بالردع الموسع الذي يتضمن استخدام مجموعه
كامله من الوسائل العسكريه الامريكيه بما
في ذلك الاسلحه التقليديه النوويه وكذلك
الدفاع الصاروخي
الجنوبي اشار الى ان كوريا الشماليه
ارتكبت عام 2022 عددا غير مسبوق من
الاستفزازات موضحا ان امريكا وكوريا
الجنوبيه تدين ما وصفه بالاجراءات الخطيره
التي تذاع استقرار الوضع في المنطقه
ومؤكدا ان التدريبات العسكريه المقبله بين
البلدين تهدف لضمان ان يقابل الحلفاء
التهديدات النوويه الكوريه الشماليه
وهو ما تحدث عنه وزير الدفاع كوريا
الجنوبيه كذلك
مؤكدامهما بالتعزيز التعاون الثلاثي مع
اليابان ايضا
حقيب اللقاء كشف بيان المشترك لبنتغون عن
اتفاق بتوسيع نطاق التدريبات المشتركه بين
البلدين هذا العامه
لوزير الدفاع الامريكي بعنوان التحالف
ويقف على اهبه الاستعداد قال فيه ان
واشنطن وصول ستجريان منورات تحاكي
سيناريوهات معقده تركز على التهديدات
النوويه في شبه جزيره الكوريه
ملوك الشيخ العربيه